MaMartine Biron, Michel C. Auge,
Alec Castonguay, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Un petit mot,
unun tour de table sur Gaétan
BaBarrette qui ne va pas
sosolliciter un troisième manda.
HiHier, avec sa cheffe derrière,
unune sortie généralement décrie
cocomme étant réussie. Qu'en
pepensez-vous Martine?
- - C'est vrai que c'est une
sosortie réussie. Je ne suis pas
totombé en bas de ma chaise. One
dodoutait bien qu'il ne se
rereprésenterait pas en 2022.
IlIl va nous manquer. Il fait
paparti de ces politiciens qui
n'n'avaient pas la langue de bo.
QuQui était assez coloré. Assez
sysympathique aussi.
C'C'est sûr qu'il n'a pas tout
réréussi. Mais au moins, on a
vavaleur juste avec lui.
IlIl a aidé de nombreux députés,
totous partis confondus, qui
avavaient des problèmes de sant.
QuQuelqu'un de très généreux, ts
inintelligent et comique.
- - Michel.
- - Moi je vais toujours me
sosouvenir d'une entrevue que ji
fafaite avec le docteur Barrett.
QuQuand ça allait mal, il venait
auau micro, vous l'avez dit.
ilil reste le micro et pouvez-vs
paparler devant de philosophie
mémédicale. En effet du temps ds
l'l'émission pour parler de ce
ququ'il avait dit tellement
c'c'était bon. Quand il parlaite
sasanté, pas de la réforme de la
sasanté ou de ce qui se passe ds
leles hôpitaux du Québec, mais e
lala santé en général, c'est un
bobonhomme fascinant.
EÉvidemmenent ça venait le
bubulldozer que vous avez décri.
MaMais on ne se change pas quand
onon arrive en politique.
- - Alec.
- - Il avait un côté Kassand, ms
enen même temps il répondait aui
àà une volonté de son
gogouvernement. Il a dit lui-mêe
enen conférence de presse avec
bebeaucoup de candeur d'ailleur.
JeJe ne l'aurais pas fait mais e
n'n'ai pas eu le choix.
C'C'était une commande d'en hau.
IlIl parlait du commissaire à la
sasanté ou de la procréation
asassistée qui devenait payante.
IlIl dit : je n'aurais pas dû
fafaire ça mais je n'avais pas e
chchoix. Beaucoup de candeur qud
mmême. Montre qu'il n'était pas
lele seul à prendre ses décisio.
C'C'est un travail d'équipe, un
gogouvernement. Il y a une parte
quque le travail d'équipe que
GaGaétan Barrette accompli qui e
vevenait pas juste de lui. Je
pepense que l'Assemblée nationae
peperd une expertise en général.
EÊtre dans l'opposition, c'est n
asassez bon vulgarisateur qui
ététait capable, dans le débat,
d'd'amener le débat plus loin.Ça
nene faisait pas l'affaire de tt
lele monde la manière était
paparfois un peu carrée.
MaMais il y avait une grande
coconnaissance de réseau de la
sasanté. Ce n'est pas pour rien
quque mes macaques le chef de
cacabinet de Legault avait beson
dede consulter une fois de temps
enen temps mais si ça ne faisait
papas l'affaire de Dominique
AnAnglade. Parce qu'il a mené un
écéclairage différent sur les
dédébats en santé. Ça m'a manquà
l'l'Assemblée nationale.
OnOn espère qu'il va rester dans
leles débats éventuellement
mémédecine n'est plus député. Ça
rereste quelqu'un d'intéressantà
écécouter.
- - La pandémie a fait
jeje pense qu'il est sorti des
lilignes partisanes beaucoup pl.
A-A-t-il déjà été dans des ligns
papartisanes, c'est une autre
chchose. Mais on se souvient qul
a a déjà été candidat de la
CACAQ. Mais bref, on voyait
ququ'avec les tweets entre autr,
il voulait donner son grain de
sesel aux débats. Martine.
EtEt avoir l'air plus positif.
- - Je pense qu'il voulait refae
soson image, se présenter
didifféremment. Il a trouvé sa
trtrès lourd de traîner sa
réréforme. Il a été ministre dea
sasanté tout le long du mandat.
CÇa a été difficile pour lui.
AlAlors il voulait redorer son
imimage. Il y avait aussi un lin
prproche, Alec en parle avec
MaMartin Koskinen, le chef de
cacabinet de Monsieur Legault, e
sosont des amis. Ils se
coconnaiaissent bien. Ils ont un
cecercle d'amis. Il se rencontre
dedes fois en dehors de la
popolitique. Et pendant la
papandémie, Monsieur Barrett avt
ququand même pas mal de contact.
IlIl a mit l'épaule à la roue
ququand c'était difficile. Comme
d'd'autres députés l'ont fait
dadans leur champ d'expertise.
MaMais Monsieur Barrette a été à
etet qu'il était prêt à servir.
- - Vous parlez de Martin
KoKoskinen. C'est intéressant. n
vava parler des 10 ans de la CAQ
ququ'on a célébrée en fin de
sesemaine. Je vous fais entendre
unun petit extrait de Monsieur
LeLegault qui, bien sûr, a dit à
seses militants : la prochaine.
OnOn redemande à la population u
QuQuébec leur confiance.
- - On a déjà, ensemble, fait
bebeaucoup de changements, maisn
a a encore beaucoup de changemes
àà faire. Puis, je pense...
j'j'ai comme l'impression qu'ona
avavoir besoin d'un autre manda.
PuPuis, ça serait plate,
ilil me semble, en tout cas,
dede casser cet élan-là.
- - Alec, je commence avec vous.
OnOn va parler des 10 ans d'abod
etet de son élan. Quand même.
DeDeux parties ont réussi, au
QuQuébec, à s'imposer.
IlIl y a le parti québécois en
191976, qui a été créés en 68.
EtEt il y a la CAQ 10 ans après
papause passait quand même un
ququatrain au pouvoir.
SuSur les 10 ans et Surla où il
esest rendu.
- - C'est un gros bouleversement
susur l'échiquier politique pare
quque la fameuse troisième voie
dodont bien des Québécois ont ré
quque Mario Dumont entre autresà
l'l'époque de l'ADQ, une voix
nanationaliste mais qui ne soit
papas souverainiste, n'havé jams
réréussi à s'imposer.
EÊtre capable d'imposer ça
auau pouvoir c'est quand même
ququelque chose. Ça a bouleversé
l'l'échiquier politique. Très
didifficile pour plusieurs parts
dede retrouver leur marque depu.
JeJe pense parti québécois entre
auautres. Mais même Parti libérl
ouou on cherche un courant
nanationaliste chez les
frfrancophones pour aller séduie
unun électorat qui a vraiment
dédéserté vers la CAQ.
CeCes complètement réaligner les
plplanètes. Est-ce que c'est
tetemporaire? Une élection ou
dedeux? On verra bien. Mais c'et
clclair qu'au-delà du personnage
FrFrançois Legault, qu'il a réui
àà amener au pouvoir, lui-même,
ilil a donné une crédibilité et
unune légitimité à un mouvemente
fofond qui n'aurait jamais pu
s's'imposer dans les années
prprécédentes. C'est en soi une
vivictoire. Est-ce qu'il aura un
auautre mandat, on verra bien.
L'L'avoir réussi à s'imposer coe
trtroisième voie c'est déjà
ququelque chose.
- - Ils ont réussi à dépasser
cecette bataille convoyait,
ététernel, entre le parti
ququébécois et les libéraux.
ReRedevenir une union.
JeJe ne ferai pas l'allié facile
avavec l'union nationale,
reredevenir une union.
EsEst-ce qu'il y a des
féfédéralistes à la CAQ,
dedes nationalistes des
sosouverainiste également. Il a
réréussi à faire ça.
- - Il a réussi à faire ça.
C'C'était aussi dans l'air du
tetemps. Il ne faut pas l'oubli.
LeLe parti québécois, à cette
épépoque, s'est mis à perdre des
dedeux côtés. À sa droite à la
CACAQ, à sa gauche avec Québec
sosolidaire qui est de nouveau
jojoueur ou dans le système.
CÇa aussi ça a contribué. . L'ue
dudu pouvoir des libéraux a
cocontribué. Mais force est de
coconstater que Monsieur Legault
auau pouvoir donne aux Québécoi.
àà un grand nombre de Québécois,
ouou à un nombre suffisant de
QuQuébécois exactement ce qu'ils
veveulent. Ça ressemble à un pai
ququébécois qui ne propose pas e
réréférendum. Le Parti québécois
plplutôt économique à la Landry
mamais ça semble être exactement
dadans les miles de ce que bien
dedes électeurs québécois, surtt
enen région, veulent.
- - Marcel vous est-il en fin de
sesemaine. J'imagine que l'humer
esest assez bonne.
QuQuand on est au zénith dans ls
sosondages, ça aide 10 ans.
- - Oui. Les gens étaient très
heheureux, ils étaient contents.
C'C'était vraiment organisé pour
nene pas qu'il y ait de problèm.
MMême le cahier des participant,
c'c'était presque de la tarte ax
popommes qu'on leur servait.
IlIl domine dans les sondages.
MoMonsieur Legault a bien cernéa
clclientèle. Dès le début du
mamandat. Il a dit : j'ai enviee
gogouverner pour la majorité, ds
QuQuébécois, et francophones.
C'C'est ça qu'il fait. Ça
fofonctionne bien.
MeMes collègues ont dit : il
prprofite aussi de la faiblessee
seses adversaires.
- - C'était le bouquet de fleurs
enenvoyées pour les 10 ans.
MaMaintenant, il y a des écueil.
EÉcouter la réponse de Monsieur
JuJulien et de Madame Guilbault
auau maire sortant de Québec qu,
enen 14 pages, explique entre
auautres pourquoi il ne trouve s
quque le troisième lien est une
bobonne idée.
JOJONATAN JULIEN, min., Énergie
etet Ressources naturelles, Quéc
- - Je comprends que M. Labeaume
esest déçu des résultats de la
dedernière élection. Je comprens
ququ'il doit faire un deuil aus.
1414 ans que M. Labeaume a mené
d'd'excellents projets pour
lala ville de Québec. Il a été
dédédié à sa ville de Québec.
EtEt aujouourd'hui, bien, c'estn
pepeu... à travers cette lettre-
llà, bien, c'est ce que je sens,
unun peu un deuil à faire,
unun peu d'amertume également.
GEGENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT,
vivice-première ministre du Quéc
- - On lui a remis une médaille
popour services rendus.
MaMaintenant, il y a une nouvele
adadministration qui d'ailleurs
s's'est fait élire avec certains
prpropositioions, notamment sur
lele tramway. Et... donc on va
trtravailler avec M. Marchand
pupuis, effectivement, je pense
quque c'est bien qu'on puisse
papasser à autre chose.
- - On n'a pas donné tous les
exextraits, mais autrement dit,
onon dit au maire sortant de
QuQuébec : merci, mais non merc.
LeLes critiques sur les tunnels,
trtroisième lien, on n'est pas
cacapable de les entendre.
C'C'est ce que ça donne comme
imimpression Martine.
- - Il y a a deux choses à dire-
dedessus, d'abord le caucus de
QuQuébec et Monsieur Labeaume, a
nene fonctionnait pas.
EtEt je vous donne juste
l'l'anecdote suivante : le tramy
s's'est réglé dans le burereau e
MoMonsieur Legault avec le
miministre des Transports
FrFrançois Bonnardel pendant que
GeGeneviève Guilbault, qui était
lala représentante de Québec,
lala ministre responsable de
QuQuébec, était à la période de
ququestions. Ça ne marchait pasu
totout entre Jonatan Julien et
MoMonsieur Labeaume.
AlAlors visiblement, ces deux-là
lului a remis la monnaie de sa
pipièce. Pour le troisième lien,
jeje dirais que c'est dans le
nanarratif de la CAQ Célestine i
c,c,est le fil qui retrousse.
OnOn le sentait aussi dans la
sasalle. Militant a dit dans la
sasalle : le troisième lien, j'i
dedes doutes pour l'environneme.
IlIl y a des députés qui trouvet
quque ça coûte cher et que
l'l'échéancier. On commence à
sosoulever et à chuchoter en
cocoulisse ou on s'en va avec le
trtroisième lien. Pour Monsieur
LeLegault, il y a un drapeau qui
sese lève sur cet enjeu.
- - Alec, et ce n'est pas en
didisant : toute forme de
crcritique, vous ne comprenez
ririen, vous n'êtes pas de Québ,
tataisez-vous, on va avancer le
dédébat.
- - Non et j'ai trouvé que d'alr
d'd'une personnalisation de ce
dédébat par rapport à la Régis
LaLabeaume, ça manquait d'élégae
etet de hauteur. La réaction de
FrFrançois Legault a été correc,
ilil a dit : Régis Labeaume estn
sisimple citoyen. Je vais lire s
lelettres et lui répondre. Mais
GeGeneviève Guilbault et Jonatan
JuJulien, honnêtement j'ai lu la
lelettre de 14 pages et ça ne ça
nene sent pas l'amertume.
EsEst-ce que le maire sortant va
êêtre du bon côté de l'histoire?
PrProbablement. Est-ce qu'il
ararrose une grande bien plantée
dede l'opposition au troisième
lilien, certainement. Ça ne fait
papas l'affaire de la CAQ.
MaMais il n'y avait pas beaucoup
d'd'amertume de politiciens déçs
dede perdre ces élections là-
dededans. D'abord, on n'écrit ps
unune lettre de 14 pages la veie
dede l'envoyer. Je pense que ça
fafait un bout qu'il avait
prpréparé. Ça manquait de hauter
àà mon avis. On dirait qu'on
esessaie de faire dévier le débt
susur les personnalités qui se
poposent troisième plutôt que
d'd'aller sur des faits. Il n'ya
papas encore d'étude. Pas encore
dede preuve que c'est une bonne
ididée, le troisième lien. Il ny
a a pas beaucoup d'experts qu'il
apapprouve. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
dadans ce temps-là?
OnOn dit que ceux qui sortent
sosont amers, ne sont pas
cocontents.
- - Montréalais ou amer.
- - Mais un moment donné il faua
susurmonter tout ça.
- - Il me semble que ça fait
plplusieurs fois qu'qu'à un momt
dodonné, il faudra, qu'il y aitn
arargumentaire, des études, un
plplaidoyer
jujuste : vous ne comprenez rie.
- - Le débat a changé de bord,
sisi vous voulez Patrice.
unune bonne idée de faire un
trtroisième lien?
dodollars.
C C'est assez pour rénover tous
leles écoles du Québec au grand
cocomplet.
EtEt elles en ont bien besoin en
papassant. C'est plus que la
dedernière... le réseau de
cecentrales hydroélectriques
HyHydro-Québec. Ces femmes
CeCe que Monsieur Labeaume est
vevenu dire c'est : avec les
memesures simples qui ne coûtent
papas cher, changer une voie de
bobord sur le pont Pierre Lapor,
onon peut probablement avoir le
mmême effet. Pour les fractions
dudu coût. Ce qui ne passe pas e
trtroisième lien maintenant
esest ce qui va en faire un enju
élélectoral dans toute la
prprochaine période électorale,-
cece sont les 10 milliards.
AlAlors qu'on n'a pas commencé à
crcreuser. Je vous passe les
dédétails de ce que ça peut être
apaprès.
- - Martine, est-ce que vous
pepensez qu'on va changer de
ststratégie?
- - Évidemment, c'est sûr que
c'c'est ces circonscriptions.
IlIl a promis. Ce n'est pas le
gegenre à mettre une croix sur e
prpromesse électorale. Ce n'est
papas du tout dans le style de
MoMonsieur Legault. Est-ce qu'iy
a a moyen de l'aménager, de voir
leles choses différemment?
C'C'est certain qu'il va passera
cacampagne électorale à défendre
cece projet. 10 milliards de
dodollars, c'est le plus grand
prprojet, plus gros investissemt
dadans les cartons de la CAQ. Et
MoMonsieur Legault n'en parle ds
auaucun discours. Il doit
cecertainement trouver que quele
chchose cloche s'il ne se vante
papas de ce projet.
- - Alec, escalope posée, il se
didit : mon avancée tellement
foforte que je traverser la
prprochaine campagne électorale
avavec ce projet?
EtEt on serait encore pouvoir.
- - Probablement. Le calcul est
cecertainement plausible.
IlIl faudra voir où il en sera e
momoment. Martine raison. Françs
LeLegault à quelqu'un...
seses forces et qualités sont au
mmême endroit. C'est quelqu'un e
trtrès persévérant qui ne lâche
papas facilement le morceau.
DaDans certains changements, son
gogouvernement veut l'imposer, e
n'n'est pas une bonne chose. Ile
sese laisse pas détourner
fafacilement de l'objectif.
LeLe défaut c'est que c'est plus
didifficile quand on a de grosss
prpromesses comme celle de les
memettre au rencard.
EtEt d'assumer les coûts
popolitiques vient avec.
EsEst-ce que dans un prochain
mamandat avec des études
enenvironnementales, quelque che
d'd'un peu plus solide, il sera
mimis de côté? Je ne sais pas.
JeJe n'arrive plus du tout
rérégulière les prochaines
élélections. Il pense pouvoir
papasser au travers avec ce
prprojet. Ils vont foncer. À mos
d'd'une surprise.
CeCe sera une décision peut-être
plplus faisable, plus facile à
prprendre dans deuxième mandat.
- - Michel, en conclusion.
- - Si c'est plus facile
d'd'abandonner une promesse quad
onon vient d'être élu, mais ça
ririsque d'être vraiment un bout
pependant toute la campagne
élélectorale à cause de la
fafacture. Ça, il n'y a pas
d'd'études qui vont changer ça.
C'C'est lui qui a dit que ça
cocoûterait 10 milliards ou plu.
IlIl y a un problème avec ça.
- - La prochaine fois on parle u
cocongrès des libéraux. Fin
nonovembre. On aura le temps.
MeMerci à vous trois. Bonne
sosoirée.